ja ich weiss allerdings gesagt dass man
das eigentlich nicht darf
nein das habe ich noch globale sprache
und keiner war dagegen dann werde ich
das jetzt mal ansprechen dass wir
dagegen sind
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge dessen megaprojekt
iq server und chemisch & rau regeln also
ich wollte mein haus weiter bauen immer
noch mit kette am start übrigens das ist
regelkonform will ich nur sagen wenn ich
bin mein haus bauen
nein ich hier connect diese ist das
regelkonform weil ich ja nichts machen
sondern einfach nur kurz meine welt
laden lastwägen so vielen kisten habe
ich längst wie jack a ja ich weiss
allerdings gesagt dass man das
eigentlich nicht darf
nein das habe ich noch gar nicht bauen
und keiner war dagegen akzeptieren
dann werde ich das jetzt mal ansprechen
dass wir dagegen sind wir haben ja
gefahren auch die machen wirklich
wir haben ja gerade auch die regelung am
laufen beziehungsweise diskussionen sehr
ausführliche diskussionen und sehr
hitzig die 30 minuten regel abzuschaffen
allerdings möchte ich jetzt nichts mehr
zu sagen feuer dann wieder diskutiert
hier ja bla bla mitbekommen kommt dann
wieder und bietet den ist nicht so ich
habe mich zweimal wetters noch mal
gesagt der agentur liegt das zentrum das
für mich
also und zwar ich hab mal probeweise
schon geschaut wie das ganze
funktioniert und es ist mega uneffizient
mein haus ist fast fertig also die
versorgung
ich kriege aus 46 kabel stone ein eisen
später raus und es würden wir
wahrscheinlich mehr materialkosten als
ich mir bringt aber ich baue seine
freunde simon sorry das nicht
unterbreche ich sage nicht was kann ich
bei euch ist kein ende
ok simon hat mir gerade geschrieben und
der meint dass er heute abend 15
diamanten und ein solar helm in der
kiste legen wird
ich bin ich im chat modus wie viel ich
hab grad auf rezept der exportmotor
clicker damit 64 im seminar gegeben aber
wieder zurück gefragt möchte ich auch
mal ein gläschen brauche ich das habe
ich glaube hier
was brauche ich noch so wir sind glaube
ich diese folge beide so ziemlich am
power kräften würde ich eine granate ich
bin dann bauen er und ich mache erst mal
ein ton leute damit man das auch noch
alles so ein bisschen hört so also ich
brauche ich verstehe das nicht ich
spreche normal wie sonst auch ins
mikrofon und auf einmal bin ich einfach
viel leiser keine ahnung wie wer skype
anrufe hat sich alles weiter gestellt
ja weil sie nicht also egal wo sollte
egal sein sagt ihnen das noch mal zwei
hiervon richtet sich sogar dass robert
an weil ich krieg aus einem roboter
sticks und da kann ich mir gleich die
holzräder zu lösen wird er scheiße habe
ich das jetzt falsch geplant so genau
hier läuft das schon rein ihr seht dass
hier sammelt sich das und die
personalauswahl ist schöne ist wir
brauchen absolut keine energie das
campos team
das kann nicht sein wir müssen hier noch
ein minimum stein zusätzlich kräften
denn das rezept ist regulär so etwas
also hier das eigentlich funktioniert
das nie und automatischen workbench
stimmt ja eine runter war guckt immer h
ist jetzt einer drin oder kommt noch
einer nacht du hast die erste weil das
rezept muss ja mal erhalten bleiben
deswegen muss man jeden fall eine kiste
platzieren und da auch noch mal ein
minimum stein reintun dann verbraucht
sich ganze zeit die haltbarkeit von dem
hintergrund ist ein umbau oder es gibt
unendlich so durch das heißt wir müssen
auf jeden fall noch minimum steigende
fahren was aber bedeutet dass wir
monster töten können
ich hab nicht alles falsch gebaut
ich halte das nur einen zuvor falsch
dahin gesetzt alter wenn das jetzt nicht
klappt alte hasen sie jetzt jeder
gemacht mein lieber
nee doch es klappt das klappt das klappt
und das ist durchaus einem dings kriegt
man nur drei klosters ist stört nicht
ein bisschen ja genau so ist ja egal ich
brauche ihn nicht so viele stars sogar
glück und nicht vorgegeben einmal vier
manchmal nur zwei manchmal drei
irgendwie so
denn ich hab ich kein queenston mehr
gottes willen
mag es einfach einen taktischen
fördermenge cobblestone ich habe genau
jetzt schon ausgemacht ach genau wir
haben ja jetzt wieder kurze nicht da das
könnte ich auch machen damit sich meine
mft auflädt sie lädt sich gar nicht mehr
auf also doch aber sehr gnädig entlädt
sich ist hier nämlich voll dieses man so
lange nicht an
es ist nacht es regnet oder spotify
herausgestellt hat das muss doch anderen
luft sein
ich musste da einmal drauf klicken damit
sieht das angeht war es geht das ist nur
manchmal an
ich dachte ich da nicht drüber sein
das bringt ja auch schon aufgefallen
windmill muss auch draußen stehen ja
aber das ist ganz speziell da muss ich
noch einiges zusammen und wurde anfangs
und zwar gibt es bei wind mit drei
komponenten einmal der wind faktor ist
absolut glücks abhängig absolut also
verschiedene biome verschiedene blöcke
haben in zufälligen gewinnt faktor wie
stark der winter ist er hat bei den
hills auf jeden fall heftig das hat
damit nichts zu tun erst mal kommen ist
es einfach nur zufall so will ich das
auch gefordert mir das geschrieben wurde
der zweite faktor ist gibt wie hoch das
ist das heißt du bist unter 160 blöcken
höhe überhaupt nicht bauen
das heißt du musst richtig hoch bauen
und das dritte ist ich glaube die
wirkung 1 9 x 9 x 9 oder irgendwie so 88
machte irgendwie sowas einen ziemlich
großen kasten drumherum
damit sie sich gegenseitig keine power
nehmen aber wenn du mich das ist in
einander hast dann entfernen die sich
nicht gegenseitig ich lasse
so entmutigt mir leid aber ich verstehe
nicht also mir zum bett ganz kurz ich
kann da kein jetpack nebenbei auf haben
nein das ist ärgerlich jetzt richtig
also die medien und steine werden
wirklich mega teuer aber ich weiß
wirklich nur weil ich es kann
ich weiß es wird nichts bringt wie viel
ist ein mini umstadt minimum stein ist
sich woche acht scherben das muss ein
paar monster töten und dann ein gold-
vier eisen das was
so viel kostet der trainer gar nicht so
viel
minimum stein an sich ist nicht teuer
aber war das passt schon
ich brauche einfach so das heißt wenn
wir jetzt hier haben sagt firmen da
kommt herein und jetzt können wir hier
auch zu bauen das macht uns nichts mehr
aber ich lasse es erstmal noch mal offen
genau und hierbei auch noch trainer
holzmann
man merkt schon die sind wesentlich
gechillt arbeiter liegt einfach daran
weil wir jetzt folge futter sind ja ich
bin auch viel ruhiger also ich bin ruhig
verläuft so jetzt können wir das ganze
spektakel sehen ich kann es ja einfach
mal hier ohne den minimum stein zeigen
und schon würde ist praktisch losgehen
unserer nächsten nebel da ganzen
goldtransport länger brauchen also
schließen beides jetzt an
es fängt an zu brutzeln und wir sehen
hier ist an sich alles da
wenn wir sehen ob im haus wenn wir
draufklicken würden wir auch einen
rauskriegen aber der erkennt erst noch
nicht das heißt hier oben kommt nichts
raus obwohl der powered und wenn ich
jetzt was ich hier tue dann auf einmal
fängt aber jedem tag sagt sie dass da
kommt doch mal raus geschossen
erst dann kann ohne jetzt ist die
haltbarkeit kaputt gegangen aber dünn
bleibt alles so wie es ist
ich bin das so krass wie sich alles
verändert hat einfach so eine komplette
stadt weil ja auch weiß auch damals war
einfach mal alles einfach alles pampa
damals alles schön verändert nicht nur
an uns da wird ja auch geil alter junge
männer plötzlich sehr sehr viele minimum
steine noch ich glaube vier stück oder
so das heißt du ja auch geschaut
es macht gar nichts wenn ich jetzt ich
habe jetzt zwar die ich muss auch mal
die goldenen transport wurde weil ich
kann ich mache alles nur weil das ganze
ist wirklich so nützt hier auch nix ich
hätte jetzt direkt da schon kräftig
daran gesetzen können also die
automatische werkbank aber zack so sieht
dies ein schöner aus und vom speed her
mache das eigentlich kein unterschied
ich habe mir letztens auch einfach mal
richtig viele generatoren gemacht
vielleicht dachte für maschinen später
brauche ich die da kann ich mich ja
jetzt direkt machen dass herein
der mann ist minimum stein wir das dann
hier steht und da klima dann leer aus
das müsste man dann wieder durch viele
zeilen das heißt ihr kommt dann rein
theoretisch wieder wird sein rucksack ab
mit mir redest den organe media
haftbefehl gegen ihn habe ich bock
aufregen soll ich mache den gleichen
abend wieder haben bei spec wieder echt
besser ausnutzen default
komisch dass das findet das alles im
zweck besser aussieht
ja ja ich werde dich nicht mehr gehört
hallo hallo
doch ich halte deswegen will ich hier
kommt leben raus und hier kommt dann
noch eine work bench hier kommt das so
dann ja erweckt freunde nach 60 folgen
kommen die ganzen leute die man das haus
wollen jetzt auch auf ihre kosten
scheiße war wetter gehen ja weg na ja
sein dass jetzt wieder voll da freut
sich ne ich dachte wenn man die so setzt
dann bleiben die ja eigentlich auch sein
können dass die so lang wie da bleiben
die blätter jetzt so wenig hinsetzt oder
nicht gehen hast du gesehen dass die
weggehen
ich weiß nicht also über die anderen
beiden bisher stehen und dann sollten so
stehen beim wenn noch einmal nach hinten
das ist nur da hinten nur bei dem ein
hier so hier kommt ob es nur bei dem bei
dem anderen nicht alles andere steht
noch wie verrückt ist das denn
das verstehe ich gar nichts mehr so an
dieser stelle gehen die ganze zeit die
blätter weg
was hast du denn jetzt zwischen sich
einbilden freunde warum die nur da die
blätter weg und da überall nicht steine
feuersteine die ganze zeit crazy braucht
zu zoomen fragezeichen
ich habe ich einen linear aber ich
glaube das wird schön also von den
ressourcen her es ist doch nicht so
aufwendig wie ich dachte das einzige was
ich vielleicht machen muss ich glaube
wenn man die monster kind kriegt man der
die häufig sogar mini um steine
ich trinke heute abend kein alkohol kein
alkohol aber geschlossen gegen die
kühlbox ich habe letzte phase da wollte
ich einfach über das gesund leben und
einfach überhaupt keinen alkohol trinken
also cash alles bleibt stehen bis auf
ein dings ist immer so schön so man
steht so auf so spät also was er spielt
10 wurde und über frage ist ehrlich
gesagt 10 uhr aufgestanden dann einfach
so gegessen sagte joggen gegangen duscht
aufnehmen dann mit freunden weg zu
kriegen erst später mein leben
vorstellen
so aber da möchte ich nur nebenbei eine
schule gehen ein paar bis ich sterbe
aber auch selbst ja also dass man auch
in die sonne rhythmus drin hat weil ich
glaube die ganze zeit vom pc sitzen
videos machen könnten nicht brauchst
eigene motivation hinter ich weiß nicht
wen ich konnte es mir das damals zählt
aber das läuft ja und ich erzähle
einfach jetzt ein bisschen privatleben
bälle raus das ist schon mal wichtig zu
wissen aus den lehren muss natürlich
dann hinter noch mit kisten dann mit dem
minimum stein genau wie hier weil ich
hier nicht weil du mir ständig brauchen
ich sag mal kurz wie ich aus cobblestone
jetzt leben mache du machst kabel stone
mit dem klub klickt einfach auf den
karten mit drauf dann siehst du dass du
da vorher stein draus machen kannst wie
und dann kriegst auf dem feuerstein mit
und ansieht was aus dem feuerstein
machen kannst so funktioniert ist
und hier machen wir einfach so zeigt das
sagen wir dass es jetzt erstmal unsere
konstruktion und hier kommt dann müsste
dann die kiste heraus kommen wo wir das
eigentlich verschwendung wir das hier so
waren doch der klub jemand bei mir aber
mal streit
so haben feuerstein geklickt den ich hab
das heft war heuer stein und mini um
steiner gibt pflasterstein war input
output so viel dass und ergibt einen
geben
jetzt war ja auch ein bisschen kabel
gleich sein aber das ist schon mal los
crash die ganze maschinerie passt
natürlich lange wege wie hier so sind
läuft das schon oder
ja es fängt er an zu ballern genau du
kannst auch ganz easy einfach kies
nehmen und das zu links machen
dies geht aus feuerstein
ja genau genau das werde ich auch noch
dazu tun dass es sozusagen alles was zu
verständigen
ich hab' ich konnte das wusste genau was
in misrata packen